hi guys this is Mark Watson for GameSpot
and I'm here with Cameron Robinson luck
and we just had the joys of indulging in
the first hands-on which is three and
given that that game has been in
development for a hell of a long time
it's amazing that this is the first time
we've had hands on you you had an issue
user well actually not issues this was
actually something that surprised me in
a good way so from the interviews at e3
in verse of the things I was worried
that The Witcher 3 might be a bit too
casual like they might have taken some
of the hardcore stuff that I loved and a
lot of people loved from The Witcher 2
and got rid of that in favor of
something because it's on console
because it's on console because it's an
open-world all those things the good
news is based on what I played which is
like three hours of the game I am no
longer worried okay so if you're worried
about that I would say don't be because
there is loads of detail in the combat
it's still hard as nails that I died a
bunch of times yeah there's lots to do
in terms of upgrading garel and pushing
making it still a big thing you don't
actually see the animation of you
meditating while you do it
but when you start meditating you like
stand up so it's still kind of in there
so all the things that made people love
The Witcher 2 for not being the same as
other a Triple A games that stuff is
still there if anything I think that you
know the fact is open-world there makes
this game even deeper you know certainly
what we found but I know the other thing
that people are gonna be wondering about
is how does this bad boy look that's
pretty good
yeah it looks pretty good I think it
looks pretty damn sweet you know when we
played the game on admittedly a very
high end like we played under perfect
conditions it was like a high-end PC
basic two of them yeah right TG takes
nine eighties in one machine and it did
look very good and the size of the world
is really impressive I mean the thing
that got me is I played a lot of The
Witcher 2 and playing the open-world
each segment of The Witcher 3 felt just
like a segment from The Witcher 2 and I
was constantly surprised how actually it
was open and I could go anywhere of
course witcher 2 was built made of these
like contained areas that you would go
down for the other yeah after you do the
sort of initial training mission you
pretty much just throw it out there and
you can do what
how are you want we played it right from
the beginning every beginning of the
game so you know one of the first things
I did was saw got him a horse wanted a
bow and then I was like I could do the
story what am I gonna do that I went off
into some side quests one of which was
incredibly difficult and actually it
would recommend it but I didn't go do it
which of course made me want to go do it
yeah I was sitting next to mark and
watching him repeatedly die it's like
ghost a wraith or it was a good life so
there was this lady and she was guarding
a Wow and it's sort of like if one of
these really cool sort of murder mystery
cycle I see I'm to find like the clues
and so if identify them at the end you
battle this lady and we get lots of cool
blue but it was incredibly difficult
battle so I wasn't leveled up but I
still managed to do it and I think
that's a testament to sort of how good
the combat is yeah yes if you can if you
nail the Dodgers or the real-time combat
and you sort of get those parries in you
can defeat some the higher-level care
yeah I think it's still the case of if
you use the correct sign which gives you
the like defensive shield that's still
your best bet
it's who as staying alive when you're
learning the ropes of the combat but I'm
the one big fight we all did was to take
their and Griffin yes that was at the
main aim of the the initial section that
we played and that fight was really
great it wasn't actually difficult
because they gave you a crossbow to help
but it was a really good introduction to
how you can approach combat you know you
had to like figure out as you always do
in these what's your games you figure
out the weaknesses of the beast and you
figure out how best from reading all the
information you can get from talking
people best to bring them down so
basically it's like The Witcher 2 but
more and an open world hello it's
gorgeous so I was excited before and I
gotta say I'm even more exciting that I
I'm super excited you know I've never
been it like the biggest Witcher player
I'm so now I play through I love most of
the wish' team I never completed edges
or other things but I'm it's really
exciting this over the world and you
know I like I said I love just being
able to wander around explore check out
some side quest throw in a bar brawl
just yeah and a cool stuff and it's it
but it's with the witch's staff and its
back
the one funny thing though they did kind
of a me go oh you guys was right at the
beginning and I was thinking I wonder if
it's gonna have the same kind of like
kind of awkward sexiness that The
Witcher 2 had like literally the first
thing you see in the game is a buck but
all right straight away there's butts
butts an AB straight away and you know
that they're obviously trying to use it
as a plot device it's not just in there
for the sake of it but I don't know I
still find it kind of I think it's just
video game you ditzies always believe
that's gonna do them out I'm coming
Valley sort of thing and also I just
can't stop thinking that someone this
spent hours crafting that love see and
people say we've got a weird job yeah
you know what we don't cross butts for a
living we don't not yet anyway for
everything else on the witcher 3 and
there's gonna be tons more content up
until the release make sure you come
back to gains for calm
you